ten tourists to come string waist
politics they weren't able to remember but no
but it's not because we're talking
about immigration for the necessarily racist
it's not because we're talking about security
necessarily knows fascist by the text
at what  you pay europe and space 3 806
think that the european union as it
is thought of today cannot
last and 6 draws in a corner france
solidarity with one spots mail carrier
atletico huge boom at the post indio
dyed socialist form rangoun nanashi
no fun  fortress the basin minister a
territory where the right has never
existed hénin beaumont and this classic
you get discount and novak
local population bandnews railway workers
politics of pride working class who
makes it the mode and marine le pen sports
ait starting to cape  times online
[Music]
I perceived myself with marine le pen
will be zero six national museums are
part by the rejection of politics
bears the name of the party the national front
the rejection of politics bears the name
of a family and which family the  pen at
hénin beaumont from sign in front of the comm
racing institute of twice ci jean
marie le pen rs3 to the long ones also of
all these practices or part by the
transformer french touch
[Music]
new types france jst by
combining country
[Music]
the  world is i just for life pride in
the full time occupation
and me greenspan sardinian women wrote
to holland hungary was born on 6 10 one
week six women not in africa in
loudes lease of prospective a walk
a speech is worth children with
the mind close the one by one from last
one night in night in many text a fact
kitchen roubaix and tourcoing fold sud
est just so intexa postwoman club
these carry your machines at the bottom
is the milk a crisis and ouazzane
tilt shift in lass  to practice genuine
fact of politico establishment we [ __ ]
you tube and five friends of Czech cinema
sarka human being commune is a member
of fo cgt union
brigitte petit at this clip you and life
as a space and activist ski jean
louis jean jacques goldman
representing the workforce  admin by day
today family goes cory jane barely
it's just by marine le pen
no but you 12
year old councilor we all lived with things where
wants to beat them
brigitte work in text to industry
interfax wiklund systra  gold fund of
jobs and a whole child find has matured my
little town is masterpiece my summer
fomc in league 1 is himself ben tally
favorite of nash switches innocent
is worth how many times can i tell my
children
you have national front i left
of the communist party their mother can be
on the square in order to have
employees shot months for me it remains only
national front and for me it is
terrible
[Music]
and not to trust the eyes of the fn to
skate human of citizens of  origin of
paragliding i want from the start of
hénin-beaumont in municipal action
a point that jogging violently and marine
le pen world first round of beijing
action whitmore dan pou type
bathroom belt rail canada xavier
bertrand  we manage to be by winning goal
com 200 l'aft ne circulatea
hénin-beaumont fomc béntendi seven
days in a better in time fn territory
and its first round of thee i drive
again me socialist but there's only been
one tactic  with beethoven and
schumann from roof or steijns from paragliding
i want you back in municipal action
july hugo cros france and sweet dé
esteem marine le pen 6 du ch pantheism
names leising café coach to a henin
beaumont
the study advocates logic this menhir  from time
to tell us
provest towards fn best steeve briois
entitled gossip lists of the mackenzie
myth of leicester croft and familia your
up floury globalization and
investment dino sony tallinn coleman has
a common form is in front of a cafe of
peace it takes belt in canada
nicolas  sarkozy a gypsy savannah
bethenod long trace by the tce which
seizes the elections me stavitskaïa fn
these prostheses for the future and that
a lot of wood and the poorest
so it is true that
when we talk about
situation difficulties for employment and
that  we're talking about helping
migrants
here too it's a shock people
don't accept we always say it's good to
pass it on for us French people we're not going to
help the others leimer pipeline hénin
beaumont
marie-france brutal brakes like that
twin mining family chichon you pen and
that I am furious situation in france
e.on finally put foreigners back
in their city pin
playable on briois that he is who and fn
he did things but good for
seniors the odd job  you have people who
are on the street in france since the euro we
have insisted that we no longer see everything is
expensive the market that's what i say
people who we would be only three
children to give them  vegetables
dairy products and meat microlights every
day it's not possible
marine le pen in her burmese pounded
bayal m like family of man
prime time where lazy marines
she carried it's no more kribi
credibility
it brought the fact that today we
care about capacity to govern jean
marie never wanted to
govern is a program which to be
defended in all patriots and which
defends above all the french vincent
16 of the european union and scott  linebrink
le pen or with between 1 and 3 15 the
european union which has made it possible with
ultra-liberalism which has allowed a
company
to get a
helping hand which, for example, I believe is
ten times less in bulgaria
much lower in poland or in
other countries
and I will go even further which has
also allowed posted workers to be
able to go from one country to another
while hitting dino wages what
world
olivier py is showing  shopping and markets
except mining family ifop nash our fans
for a white coat
french people well I guess so far
from loaches not racist there are certain
things that should be reviewed to
welcome this legend because
well we already have a lot of unhappy people  in
france we welcome some from certain countries
and well the president has privileges
foreigners than the french but hey
afterwards i'm not racist
it's true that they need to be
helped it's war at home cécile
it's  there but frankly
in france we should regulate fate we
leave it a little steeve briois we have to use
our files 1% seven days off the
twingo
laurine taxi fixing of running of all
peoples want to regain power a little
compared to the elites
they want to fight  against this
globalization which
but full of unemployed people we see it
so concretely reminds me of brigitte what did it do to
you to see
that at one good word the mayor and the
national front that's what was for me cab
for me it was a
disaster i couldn't hold back my
tears
hénin beaumont is humble and chews
like marine le pen shock strategy and
10 no longer sang when you see him
move green party drop in m number
edge jean marie le pen had  installed the
national front but
regularly provoke public opinion
through verbal outbursts on a
river smelling good of anti-Semitism
bad historical taste revisionism
and it is to counter the pen decided to
put an end to these excesses she had the d
a success since a part of the
voters too finally that the
speech of marine le pen is a
speech of common sense which can federate a large
number of voters le pen
this sensor has become a perilous
and safe match
or will it be d  euros we are in
favor we were going to know the exit from
the european union being better is what we are going to
do we are going to reorganize
europe in France 9 to europe a
europe that respects the peoples of europe
that respects sovereignty
we can work have some
with other peoples on the contrary we
have a lot in common it is the
chinese mystification origin
we have a
culture nevertheless common in europe
it is the same religion after all
appreciated it is forbidden to say that
n  is this not the pen in fuji jokes
endgame ivanine hey yes the municipal maya woman
say hostile the act at
opening tabligh protein base
but britney get back to score
atmospheres windows cafe quickly tin
zaw win sum local discover or
movies inc  doc painting by bfm one man
and you wish you this ankama match
the end of the month of things that the gentleman
who told you about not the only ones cut
for him
good I don't forget right the
fed up
with the traditional right  are not
national mad in essence
they were priests of the socialist party
everything has not been everything is not
over yet since unfortunately there is
still a part of the French who
think that we are the devil a
small part but a part when  even so
this process of demonization and
well must continue to show who
we really are that said we can not
take and present ourselves as we are
while having our own ideas on
immigration I think that we must be
intransigent the national priority
that  doesn't mean that we want to
throw all the Arabs into the sea in anger
because that's what we know what we
can hear not only it's
giving priority to the French
whatever their origins he says to the  from
france richie from the fn cim du havre 8 de
ban joined in strategy arthur
reparti featuring hénin beaumont in fine from the
fmi denies the fact of signing bruno cazau
[Music]
wilkinson beat entrust I pay you with a
keyboard berthen four years and  we were talking
about numbers we were talking more to people and
we were talking more about people and then I
also understood that the national front
could really win, sonally the
national front is the symbol of a
political system that no longer meets the
expectations of the people  french
marine le pen believe closing on
monday
small nap experience of the tops of
france yes you go the acda 12 miles
from the panic of the topvent like the
previous days of action which them
despite rudy toxic is a strategy
figures shocks winning the presidency of
the rhino canso because mainstream
all want to take left bac you
had berton and the black bag
the cnct of apple it circulates me in the
presidential access
so goes the national front me it
scares me desperate who want a
total change is d  'about that after I tell myself
to do with the elections if it's if
one day a single national front and
will even notice everything can
happen
yes I think that now everything is
possible everything and everything is possible I
think that  she can win the
french presidential election and action ashton dînent
turballe between marine le pen spitak
zionist and anti immigration of the
world and first world rookie 116kg
joke
hénin-beaumont d'amstrad had done a
parody pinto french touch and yes we
them  elections the ps like martine two
de facto frenchies mme french pro ex
wife agnès du com
[Music]